je suis attaqué en plein jour crac aulas
il manque 300 brebis ima chèvre je sais
pas ce qu'on va récupérer dans ses
calculs la moindre faille de l'éleveur
ou du berger va être potentiellement
exploité par le savent qu'ils sont
surveillés tout le temps
qui savent pas où ils savent que ça va
frapper quoi
je surveille toute la nuit à l'aide de
la caméra thermique c'est un animal qui
est très difficile à trouver il est
nulle part parce qu'on ne voit pas en
fait il est partout parce que dès qu'on
compte il en manque
salut à tous et sur isner ce jeu avec
tanguy de la chaîne tout pète salut tout
le monde
on en haute savoie dans les alpes on est
là pour parler du métier de berger
on est venu passer du temps avec des
bergers leur poser des questions sur
leur quotidien mais aussi sur une
problématique qui les concerne fortement
celle d'un prédateur mais nous
là c'est ton bureau en fait ouais c'est
le bureau tu vois c'est beau on a les
glaciers c'est pas beau c'est incroyable
comme bureau la cabane aller un peu plus
haut on la voit pas mais quand tu es de
la cabane tu vois le mont blanc tous les
matins quand tu te lèves c'est un alpage
vous gardez moi il ya trois ans et c'est
des brebis qui arrive du sud de la
france
on y va
m
le métier de berger c'est vraiment un
triptyque relationnel entre le troupeau
le berger et les chiens c'est ce petit
monde là se connaît et travailler
ensemble comme ils savaient le nay copie
magnifique naiko il ya un an et demi
c'est un pasteur bâche qu un berger
basque
il n'y a pas que des chiens de berger
avec les bergers il ya aussi des chiens
de protection entre guillemets un groupe
moins un peu et pas tout donc on a des
chiens en fait qu'ils sont avec le
troupeau à l'année et qui sont là pour
écarter tout danger du troupeau et qui
alerte aussi le berger quand il lance
aussi sa limite un peu les attaques
qu'on perd beaucoup de chiens tous les
angles qui se font tuer par les loups
elles ont quand même une belle team de
sécurité c'est beau bien entre trop
attention de berger tond pas tous les
partants ça suffit pas il ya 2500 moby
qui sont mortes dans passer sous leurs
cros du loup tous 1500 juste en france
juste enfance et ouais c'est beaucoup on
a que 500 loup en france donc ça fait un
bon ratio
[Musique]
historiquement le loup étaient présents
soit environ 90% du territoire de la
france
au 18ème et 19ème siècle mais à l'époque
l'imaginaire français associent le loup
un animal dangereux pour l'homme la
légende de la bête du gévaudan qui
raconte qu'un loup aurait tué une
centaine d'hommes entre 1764 1567 entre
est une sorte de psychose nationale
pendant plusieurs décennies
traqués et chasser dans tout le pays il
disparaît complètement au début du 20e
siècle
vers les années 1930 les loups sont
réapparus en france en 1992 dans le parc
du mercantour le retour des loups en
france on en a vu dans l'arrière pays
niçois
depuis six mois on relève en permanence
des indices de présence traces du rin
excréments touffe de poils et carcasses
le loup ne présente aucun danger ni pour
les troupeaux ni pour l'homme en france
en 2018 l'office national de la chasse
et de la faune sauvage argens et les
nous dans 40 départements
il est aujourd'hui au moins 72 meute
toutes situées dans les alpes et la
provence
c'est donc forcément aussi dans ces
régions que les éleveurs subissent la
majorité des partis en france il ya une
problématique du loup parce que ce
prédateur carnivore peut s'attaquer à
les animaux domestiques notamment des
ovins comme les brebis les agneaux les
moutons mais aussi des chèvres parfois
des vhu et plus rarement des poules et
ça impacte le travail des éleveurs et
surtout des bergers qui sont en charge
de la protection de ses troupes
à l'essai n'a pas de chance c'est pas
quand la saison des myrtilles
tu aurais pu en avoir la joie fait à la
saison des mollets là tu vois verger
s'est un peu de persil frais c'est pas
plus tu es là et quand va attendre au
pop up là haut les moutons je vais pas
comment il fait pour marcher alors que
c'est comme ça on grimpe lui marche
puisque l'effet d'un chien qui prévient
là qui nous a vus voilà qu'on est dans
son territoire qu'on est au niveau des
brebis
on va avancer tout doucement on va lui
parler
ça va un axe très bon là le chien il a
bien fait ce truc de la vente a vu cyrus
on reconnaît un vain mot chien
ah bah c'est bon tu veux jouer le loup y
es tu à bouger ah bah c'est bon on peut
y aller
quand c'est ce que joseph cantalou
j'attaque genre il arrive là en pleine
journée et plein de bobby est parti il
ya plusieurs configurations là on est
dans un milieu ouvert donc on peut le
voir arriver souvent il se cacher ils
ont un pelage ça se confond un peu avec
la roche
ce qui nous fait remarquer qu'ils
allouent qui est présent souvent c'est
que le troupeau va s'affoler d'un coup
va partir dans tous les sens là où le
troupeau il estoit tous ensemble une
cohésion d'une cohésion et si le
troupeau se met à attaquer on va voir
soit un lot qui part à droite sur un lot
qui part à gauche
les loups sont malins quand ils sont en
mode souvent ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
attirent les chiens d'un côté pour
laisser les deux autres attaques et de
l'autre ça laisse un trou ouverts et ils
font quoi il les consomment sur place où
ils vont les traîner les autres
d'ailleurs pareil a pas de règle soit
c'est consommer sur place soit c'est
juste égorgé parce qu'il faut tu vois
pour la crédit la brebis là quand même
c'est quoi si géniaux ça passe quoi sur
ce 50 60 kg ça a pesé de 45 à 75 kg mais
on a déjà vu des loups traîner leurs
proies sur 7 km cette étude les nerfs et
on voit que c'est du groupe à ce que les
eaux sont brisés ce qu'un chien peut pas
faire c'est une super espèces parce que
la manger il ya à manger dont il ya des
chevreuils des chamois etc
sauf que pour lui c'est bien plus facile
d'aller attaquer notre peau ouais c'est
ça c'est l'opportunisme en fait c'est
dur il va aller calculer la dépense
d'énergie par rapport à son gain elles
vont passer là
et des fois tu fais passer le col et le
loup lui l'attend de l'autre côté
[Musique]
ça fait cinq ans que je suis bloqué on a
le droit de le faire jusqu'à l'âge de 75
ans donc
en cours de la marche
on n'est pas du tout rémunéré on est
bénévole on a un métier à côté et on
intervient uniquement sur arrêté du
préfet ça peut être du renard des
poulaillers sa fête du saint denis et
dans les champs de maïs et ça peut être
du loup sur les troupeaux on les suit on
va dire entre parenthèses toute l'année
par l'intermédiaire des pièces photos et
nous ici chez nous de la neige
là on va les voir en pièce photo qui a
été installée en plus le début d'hiver
et les pêches photos qui sont sécurisées
à part un boîtier en faire un câble pour
éviter qu'on vende ou les vols parce que
c'est très prisé ben voilà et basile a
été fait exprès celui la première photo
il ya un loup qui arrive dans le champ
du piège photo
le loup est un animal particulièrement
fantomatique
il fait partie des animaux qui ont une
culture et les loups en europe sont
persécutés depuis des millénaires donc
ils ont parfaitement intégré cela et
donc ils savent se faire extrêmement
discret même pour les naturalistes qui
espèrent le voir c'est un véritable
graal
[Musique]
au niveau du matériel qu'on utilise la
nuit pour l'heure la surveillance de
troupeaux donc une chose déjà
indispensable ça s'appelle une caméra
thermique sa détecte la chaleur et ça
nous permet de repérer des animaux
loigné pouvoir tirer en sécurité l'autre
matériel cannabis et voilà c'est une
arme donc c'est une carabine qui permet
de tirer aussi bien du sanglier que du
ser fée qui est très efficace pour tuer
parce que le but le but c'est de le tuer
et qui partent pas blessé dans la nature
sur du logement su service deux fois on
me dira efficacement quoi puisque nous a
été prélevée et une fois le loup a été
manquée donc du court il est toujours en
train de promener en 1949 la france a
ratifié la convention de berne qui
interdit de chasser le lourd sans
autorisation l'article 1 stipule
notamment que la convention est là pour
assurer la conservation de la flore et
de la faune sauvage et de leur habitat
naturel pour réguler la population de
l'eau des tirs de prélèvement
c'est à dire la possibilité de tuer
l'animal sont autorisés à chaque année
entre septembre et décembre
en 2009 le gouvernement a donné son feu
vert pour que 17% des loups soit abattue
contre 10% auparavant
les années précédentes
si on chasse en dehors de ces quotas ont
fait on fait ce qu'on appelle du
braconnage donc ça peut ça peut coûter
très cher notamment bon des amendes et
retraits de permis
si c'est déjà arrivé que si des gens se
font attraper avec du très gros
braconnage font même la prison
en fait on le déteste pas mais c'est
juste que toi la fin de la saison un peu
plus quartz été crevés toi recèlent en
fait il que c'est à dire celle font en
fait c'est comme s'il y avait quelqu'un
qui était sur ton et steve avec un fusil
avec une lunette tu le voyais jamais et
tu sais qu'il pouvait tirer au moindre
moment être blessé voilà il blesse les
brebis tend to quit brestois parce que
moi l'an passé à cause de la fatigue
mais je suis tombé je me suis cassé le
coude chercher veut mettre partout les
larmes aux yeux parce que j'ai perdu mes
chers au château il était depuis j'en
pouvais plus passer jusqu'à thabo avoir
de l'aide des éleveurs et de ça un
moment tu as les nerfs qui craque pas
assurable tu peux pas toute la journée
surveiller t'es bête et puis toi notre
boulot c'est de faire manger nos bêtes
entretenir des espaces et on empêche de
le faire et en plus on dit que tu as un
mauvais bergers parce que t'as qu'à
garder des brebis et mémoire gros bill
sui quart d'heure par jour
y a personne qui neige qui vendent sous
la pluie j'y suis
[Musique]
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir ma femme avec
moi j'ai une chance fabuleuse de l'avoir
parce que quand tu es tout ça je peux
dire que tu peux te les plombs faut
avoir les nerfs bien accroché et être
passionné parce que sinon tu tiens pas
quoi sale temps des salles eux le
stressait du coup c'était
au quotidien il fallait prendre sur soi
donc notre vie de couple n'en pâtissent
pas du coup ça transmet son stress
weight à quelques joutes angoisse fois
est ce que si vous aviez le droit de
vous défendre face aux loups ça changera
quelque chose
non le l'an passé j'avais une carabine
dans le sac
la seule chose que ça a changé c'est ma
dépense énergétique s'apaisent ça pèse
lourd et tard la vue une fois en pleine
journée et a pas le temps de dégainer ça
dure cinq secondes c'est hyper rapide et
puis tu es enfant avoir une carabine
dans la dans la cabane chargé c'est
toujours pareil avec les gosses donc
voilà je pense c'est pas la fin pour
nous en tout cas on n'est pas berger
pour ce à quoi
ah ouais ok ouais je sais en fait
regardez démonstration ce parti
attention qu'est ce qu'il faut pas faire
allez c'est parti d'autres monnaies
malin
laisse toi qui sais métailié je pense
même que cela
[Musique]
c'est quoi pour toi la solution
aujourd'hui alors j'imagine demain tu es
président tu ferais quoi concrètement
c'est un gros bordel n'y a pas de suivi
écologique tout le monde parle du loup
personne c'est con mais se comporte
certes tous ceux qui t'explique que ça
attaque la nuit que c'est pas possible
ça s'approche de l'homme etc
c'est des gens qui connaissent rien ils
ont juste vu le loup dans les livres on
en parlait au xviiie siècle et c'est
tout où les gamins qui allait garder il
faisait claquer les sabots et puis le
loup fuyez aujourd'hui c'est plus du
tout comme ça on a des
environnementalistes qui veulent
absolument pas qu'on puisse les loups ou
l'émeute pour savoir où elles sont pas
ce qu'elles pensent que grâce aux puces
âge on va aller les tuer enfin je veux
dire il ya une espèce de paranoïa
schizophrène où tout le monde se méfie
de tout le monde et du coup il se passe
plus rien et tout le monde et personne
n'est content il ya eu une période où la
cohabitation loup le berger la
cohabitation elle peut pas exister
il n'y a pas de cohabitation possible
via une coexistence possible mais pour
qui est co existence il faut qu'il y ait
réciprocité
on est deux prédateurs en haut de la
chaîne alimentaire et dans n'importe
quel milieu quand il ya deux prédateurs
sur un même territoire
l'un et l'autre savent que s'ils vont
sur le territoire de l'autre il ya un
risque létal aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui le loup il est surprotégé et
puis on a des phénomènes d'hybridation
qui sont compliquées avec les chiens
aussi qui créent des comportements
complètement anormaux coup ce qu'on
voudrait c'est pas qui est plus douce et
qui est zéro brebis tuées
[Musique]
par rapport à la montagne au
pastoralisme en montagne ce sera
difficile d'avoir le zéro dégâts l'idéal
ce faire quoi il faudrait attendre c'est
essayer de d'intégrer la contrainte du
loup la réduire à son maximum mais en
sachant bien que on pourra pas
totalement la faire disparaître ça
devrait passer à 10 7 % de prélèvements
on sait très bien qu'il ya 20% de
reproduction donc ça veut dire qu'on
n'est toujours pas en phase de
stabilisation
on est toujours en phase d'augmentation
c'est plutôt une gestion par la
vengeance de l' oeil pour oeil dent pour
dent
comme pour faire baisser une pression
sociale or est-ce qu'on veut uniquement
faire baisser la pression sociale ou
faire baisser la prédation ça c'est
vraiment la question et c'est ce sur
quoi il faut travailler
[Musique]